an ordinary everyday looking man but in
truth the most prolific rapist in
British history
that's how Indonesian arraign hard-ass
Onaga has been described in the UK where
he has been sentenced to life in prison
for sexual offences against 48 men but
police suspect the number of men he
drugged raped and then filmed is closer
to 195 here's more on what the court
described as his campaign of rape green
arts Onaga would leave his apartment in
the early morning hours to go hunting
for victims stalking the streets of
Manchester he preyed on vulnerable often
drunk men offering them help casting
himself as the Good Samaritan in fact
the judge who heard his case called the
36 year old student an evil serial
sexual predator burnouts Onaga is a
depraved individual a sexual predator
who was offended we believe in
Manchester for over 10 years and he has
taken advantage of young men in the city
centre who came to our vibrant and safe
city for a night out with their friends
Sanaa Gaz crimes followed a pattern
first he lured the men back to his city
centre home offered them a drink spiked
with drugs when they fell unconscious he
raped them and filmed them keeping
phones as trophies his crime spree
stopped on this bathroom floor when one
victim woke up and fought back thus
leading police to uncover his years long
sexual assaults on potentially hundreds
of unsuspecting men some of them may
know that they have been a victim of a
crime some of them may not so therefore
I think it's important about what we
don't want to do is further traumatize
young men but what we do want to do is
provide any support that we can during
sentencing the judge said sir Naga must
spend a minimum of 30 years in prison
for his crimes earlier I spoke with DW
correspondent Prieta kusuma in Jakarta
and asked her what details have emerged
there abouts Onaga
this has become trended nationwide since
yesterday and the local international
media
really pulled a lot of attention to this
we actually didn't get really much of an
information about him since until this
morning the local media tried to reach
his family but they still refused and
says no to the media and we totally
understand about that all we know is
that he was born in jump Indonesia and
actually grew up in a very well of
conservative Catholic family in Sumatra
he was studied in university of
indonesia back in 2002 and then later
continuous muster in Manchester UK and
later in Barca's PhD on human geography
and University of Leeds all we know is
that his parents actually knew nothing
about his true character and was shocked
to find out about this and we also
talked to the Indonesian Student
Association and they were shocked to you
know receiving this news